on 23rd August 2019 after you had
attacked and set fire to her 21 years
previously on the 18th of April 1998.
Jackie was in her early 30s in the 1990s
she was outgoing optimistic and
confident with a wide circle of friends
and was a close and loving mother to her
late teenage son Shane delliston and
young daughter Sona Chandler Kirk she
had wide-ranging interests and a free
spirit intending to travel and see the
world
she also had a great sense of humor
which was something that would keep her
going later on
her generosity and open-mindedness led
her to give you shelter when you were
homeless in 1995 after a chance meeting
you then moved in and began an
exploitative and coercive and
controlling relationship with her
your drug and alcohol abuse led her back
to drug and drink problems that she had
previously conquered
you're abusive and undermined her
self-confidence as you became
increasingly violent towards her
she became withdrawn from family and
friends and eventually sauna now aged
around nine or ten moved in with Shane
because of the intimidating and volatile
atmosphere you created in her home
Jackie became too frightened of you
to make you leave her house and she had
nowhere else to go
on one occasion you cracked her
cheekbone on another she was in hospital
with a fractured jaw on more than one
occasion who threatened to burn her
Flacco you frequently threatened to kill
her
he repeatedly watched a scene from
Reservoir Dogs when a young policeman is
tortured in a chair before being
satellite with petrol
Jackie described you watching the film
with a permanent grin and that you liked
seeing the torture
you enjoyed acting like the characters
in the film
three days before what proved to be the
Fatal attack in Western on Superman
when Jackie had refused to give you some
money that she had in her bank account
you were violent and aggressive towards
her and even locked her in a bath
station toilet
railway station toilet it was some hours
before she was freed by a cleaner
against that background Jackie was too
vulnerable and scared to refuse when you
told her you were using her car to take
you both to Plymouth
she agreed so as not to upset you and
for fear of another beating
you planned to do really serious harm to
Jackie on that trip
nursing some imagined grievance about a
former boyfriend of hers
on the journey you told Jackie that you
had arranged for her to be killed by a
gangster named Charlie from York and you
boasted that Jackie's name was top of
his hit list and it was too late to stop
it you taunted her in the car with the
Assassin's progress down south
it was not clear if the trip out of bath
was to avoid or to facilitate an
encounter with a Charlie but either way
it was said to further disempower and
frighten Jackie and she was very scared
because she knew of your capacity for
violence even if she didn't believe the
story about Charlie
as you drove away from Bath you stopped
at a petrol station and filled up an
empty Coke bottle with petrol there was
no need the tank had enough petrol it
alarmed Jackie as she had never known
you do this before and she knew of your
interest in fires
it reminded her of an approve of a
previous occasion when you went into her
bedroom when she was asleep and you
doused her and the bed from a man can it
went over her face and upper body and
you said to her
I just have to Chuck a match and you'd
go up
the journey diverted to Western Superman
knew became increasingly agitated and
violent and repeatedly and forcefully
struck Jackie while you were driving
your mood was then Karma to begin with
in Western and you both spent time on
the beach and driving around and slept
in the car overnight
you were drinking heavily
later that day your mood turned hostile
you were both in Jackie's car in the car
park in Oxford Street and you told her
that you would torture her
you were swearing and verbally abusing
her and you forced her to do and say
what you wanted to exert total control
over her
who then punched her in the face drawing
blood
he ordered her to pass you the coke
bottle full of petrol
you made her Bend her head over down
over her knees and poured the petrol
from the coke bottle over her head and
neck and then you got out of the car
Jackie who is truly frightened now had
petrol all over her head in her eyes and
on her hands where she had tried to
protect her face
she also got out of the car as she
thought it would be safer
you offered her a cigarette taunting her
that it might be her last and when you
when she refused you said
smoke it or I'll Chuck it at you let's
see how calm you are now
you lit your lighter and Jackie saw the
lighter flame going across her face as
she was ignited
you shouted at her to stay away from you
with the lighter still in your hand
Jackie recalled everything slowing down
in her head at that point she could feel
her arms on fire and the pain from the
burning and recalled shouting or trying
to shout help me
but beyond telling her to roll over you
did not help her and you did not call
for help
she rolled over on the ground which at
first seemed to put out the fire but it
then reignited and you told her to roll
again
a passerby alerted a police patrol car
and an ambulance was called they found
Jackie no longer in frames Flames now
but still conscious and in agony with
extensive Burns
her teeth and nose were black and all
the hair on her head eyebrows and
eyelashes had been burnt off those
pictures were too distressing to show to
the jury in our recent trial but in any
event they weren't directly relevant
the skin on her face and hands had been
burnt off showing the pink flesh below
she was also bleeding heavily from her
nose and upper lip area and the police
officer noticed that your left
non-driving hand was covered in blood
which was her blood from you hitting her
earlier
when you asked about what had happened
by the first officer to arrive at the
scene you falsely told him that you had
dragged Jackie out of the car after she
had caught fire and that you had put the
Flames out
you denied that Jackie had any relatives
which meant that there was a delay in
Shane and sauna being told about their
mother which was gratuitously callous
in your five police interviews you
continued to lie about what you had done
at one point you appeared even to be
blaming Jackie falsely saying that she
had spilled petrol on herself when she
filled the tank tank from the coke
bottle and it was she who then lit a
cigarette
Jackie's injuries as we have heard were
life-threatening and life-changing
when she first arrived at Western super
mayor a e Department it was not clear
that she would survive
She was transferred to the Intensive
Care Unit at frenchay hospital here in
Bristol where she remained for three and
a half weeks requiring intensive support
to keep her alive
she had external significant Burns to 35
percent of her body including face neck
chest hands torso upper thighs and
buttock
the burn injuries were full thickness to
her neck and upper chest and deep
partial thickness Burns to her hands and
thighs she was unrecognizable as sauna
and Shane have explained she also had
severe inhalation injuries her mouth was
burnt and she had burned to her
respiratory tract and into her lungs
her vocal calls cords were left in a
fixed and closed position
a tracheostomy was inserted on the 1st
of May 1998 which allowed her to
continue breathing essentially bypassing
her vocal cords and it remained in place
until her death
she required 14 operations including
skin grafts and spent eight and a half
months in hospital before being released
on the 7th of January 1999.
initially Jackie protected you but after
she learned the second victim a year
later felt able to tell the police what
you had done to her
you intended to inflict really serious
violence and cause Jackie really serious
harm on that road trip and it was a
planned and premeditated attack
looking at the case today I cannot be
sure that you filled the coke bottle
with petrol specifically so that you
could burn Jackie later and act out the
scene from Reservoir Dogs
and I must therefore give you the
benefit of the doubt on that point
but there is no doubt that you planned
and intended to engage in a gratuitous
deliberate and monstrous attack on
Jackie during that road trip
with whatever means at your disposal and
to intimidate her psychologically to
cause maximum physical and mental pain
over a period of days
in October 1999 Jackie described the
devastating and life-changing effect the
injuries had had on her both physically
and psychologically
you have heard her statement being read
in court today
but even in this statement she
underplayed the extent of her disability
and focused on the positive
sauna and Shane gave a more unvarnished
account of how hard it had been for
Jackie as did the medical experts that
we heard from at trial
she was always in pain and suffered from
depression and Nightmares and was
suicidal at times
her courage to survive in defiance of
her injuries and Trauma shines out in
her statement and she was determined to
give evidence at your trial in 2000.
as we've heard you were convicted of
causing Jackie Grievous bodily harm with
intent on the 10th of May 2000. you
received a discretionary life sentence
with a notional determinate sentence of
18 years and a specified period of nine
years
at the same time as you were convicted
and sentenced for the attack on Jackie
you were also convicted of the gbh and
rape of another woman on the 23rd of
January 1999.
who incidentally you had started a
relationship with shortly after you had
burnt Jackie
for those offenses you were given a
notional determinant sentences of six
and eight years respectively
Jackie and her family were told that she
would live for just another 10 years
because of the injuries you had caused
her
against the odds she survived for more
than twice that to see her children
married to know her grandchildren
with the help of her family especially
devoted Sona and Shane and good friends
she was determined to lead as full a
life as she could
but her injuries and disfigurement were
horrific
her lungs and breathing were permanently
damaged
and breathing was difficult
eating and drinking was hard because of
both her very restricted mouth opening
and the tracheostomy
she was in and out of Hospital in the GP
surgery with complications for the rest
of her life
although she had no vocal cord she tried
to learn to speak again but it was very
challenging and frustrating for her not
to be understood
she suffered abuse in the street because
of the extent of her facial scarring
but she sold it on and continued to go
out when she could
in August 2019 Jackie's intestines
became swollen for some unknown reason
the extent of extensive scarring to her
body meant that unlike normal skin
her abdomen could not expand to
accommodate the swelling
as a result the pressure inside was too
great her diaphragm ruptured and her
bowel forced its way up into her right
lung cavity causing her lung to collapse
and impacting on her breathing
she was too frail for surgery and the
doctors had to tell Sonna and Shane that
her life could not be saved
Shane and son are rushed to be with her
comforting and loving her in her final
few hours as she died
even then she was Fearless
asking Sona to tell her if she was dying
you had caused her death by setting fire
to her and as the jury unanimously found
you had murdered her
Jackie's death caused unimaginable pain
for her children and family
I want to pay tribute to the courage of
sauna and Shane for their Victim Impact
students eloquently describing their
mother and their loss
I couldn't help with thinking what her
credit they both were to themselves and
to Jackie
and how proud she would have been if she
could have heard sauna read her
statement in court today
just as they were so proud of her
I shall now turn to you
you were born on the 23rd of May 1964
and are now aged 58.
you were 33 when you set fire to Jackie
and 55 when she died
you do not appear to have had a troubled
background
you did well exams and qualified as an
electrician
you have however got a considerable
number of previous convictions nine
convictions for 18 offenses between 1986
and 1997 matters such as theft burglary
public order offenses and drink and Drug
offenses
although none were for serious violence
you were convicted for assault
occasioning actual bodily harm which
cannot have been a trivial matter since
he received a nine-month custodial
sentence
and shortly before this offense you were
convicted for possession of an offensive
weapon
but since there were no serious violence
matters I shall treat your previous
convictions as neither an aggravating
nor a mitigating Factor but merely
neutral
at 16 you were experimenting with
drinking drugs and by 21. you are
injecting amphetamine and you're a
heroin addict by 23.
you are unsuccessful in Breaking Free
from drinking drugs and have been
drinking heavily for several days when
you attack Jackie in 1998.
after your sentence in 2000 you were
released from prison on the 25th of
September 2015 when the parole board
considered it safe but you were recalled
on the 8th of June 2018. you had resumed
drinking and were not open and honest
with your offender manager
you have now acknowledged that you're an
anti-alcoholic and have enrolled in the
alcoholics 12 steps program
on 2nd April 2019 you are again released
on license with a number of conditions
until you recalled to prison for this
matter
I have read the parole board papers
I can see that there are some positive
steps that you've tried to take to
acknowledge your issues around alcohol
and you have expressed a desire to
practice abstinence
but until recently you have also
continued to minimize your
responsibility for your crimes
blaming the offenses on alcohol and also
at times partly on the victims
I've taken account of the statement from
the mother of your two children from 40
years ago that I was given this morning
at court
that I cannot accept her assertion that
you have always been remorseful in light
of two matters firstly your behavior
after the attack and secondly the full
file of parole board papers
you have however now accepted that the
violence against Jackie was planned and
that the road trip was a ruse to carry
out the attack
you have acknowledged what the parole
board rather
politely describe as your adversarial
attitudes to women
and you now admit having sought Revenge
out of jealousy and perceived slights
when you attacked Jackie
you were also candid enough to admit to
the parole board that when you panicked
after you had set fire to Jackie your
Panic was more for your own safety than
for Jackie's
to your credit your behavior and custody
has been largely good
on one occasion you were described as a
model of an enhanced level working
prisoner and I have also noticed that
you received an excellent reference from
the manager of the Great Dane adoption
society when you did community service
day release
foreign
that a life sentence is mandatory and I
must specify the minimum term of
imprisonment which you will be required
to serve by reference to schedule 21 of
the sentencing Act 2020.
as I am satisfied that the date of the
offense of murder was committed on the
day that Jackie died for the reason set
out in my separate judgment
I conclude that the starting point for
your offense under the schedule must be
30 years
as the seriousness of the offense is
particularly high for a number of
reasons
your conduct was sadistic
from the build up to the attack from the
time you left bath two to three days
earlier
and deliberately setting a higher head
and chest on fire as you did
anyone who uses Petrol in an attack on
others must be aware of the level of
seriousness of their actions
and your use of when your attack was
planned and premeditated even though I
accept you did not bring it to the scene
in the formal sense
deliberately
causing really scary in serious injury
by fire is likely to involve Agony for
the victim and the possible possibility
of permanent injury or disfigurement
just as it did here even when there is
no intention to kill
Mr tarani has relied on the case of
Dunstan to argue for a starting point of
25 years in a case of death by fire
but Dunstan is a something of an outlier
amongst the authorities more relevant is
the recent case of stancio
which endorsed the law chief justice
judgment in Jones of 2005 that
deliberately really serious injured
injury by fire May justify a 30-year
starting point
Dunstan was not referred to in stanzio
but the court in stanzu will no doubt
have been aware of it
there are also important differences in
the facts between the cases
unlike Mr dunstan's attack on his victim
your attack on Jackie was premeditated
but even if I had accepted this 25-year
starting point urged on me by your
Council there were so many aggravating
features in your case that would have
required an uplift to over 30 years it
becomes a distinction that would make no
difference to the overall sentence
so having reached a starting point I
must then consider any aggravating
features that are not already factored
into the starting point itself
these are in your case the history of
your pattern of increasing violence
towards Jackie her vulnerability as your
partner and the abuse of trust that that
entails
the chilling way in which you forced her
into submission and tried to bend her to
your will with your abusive behavior and
your misogyny over the months and years
your extreme state of drunkenness over
the entire trip to Western Superman is
also an aggravating feature
so too is your cowardly Behavior after
you had set Jackie on fire
ordering her to stay away from you to
protect yourself from getting burnt
rather than helping to extinguish the
fire
you did not even get the duvet from the
car for her
yet even whilst drunk you had the
audacity to play the hero to the police
when first asked about what happened
you then maintained your lies and five
police interviews making up a story
about a group of jobs and suggesting it
was Jackie's fault for spilling the
petrol onto her own clothes and lighting
a cigarette
but there are two further outstanding
significant aggravating features
the first aspect is the level of sadism
and extreme nature of the attack
culminating in the fire on the road trip
which takes it above the factors built
into a 30-year starting point
it was just so callous and so brutal
the second
is the physical and mental suffering and
terrible scarring that Jackie has
endured for 21 years when she tried to
make the best of what was left of her
life
as she described it every time she
looked in a mirror or saw the response
of others to her scarring or even
touched her face she was reminded of
what you had done
it was compounded by the impact on her
family and friends
we have heard this morning how sauna
aged just 13 assumed a parental and
carer's role which robbed her of a
normal teenage and mother-daughter
relationship
Jack his determination to make the best
of things by taking up photography as
she could not use her hands to paint
by getting a dog Molly to keep her
company and her bravery ignoring the ACT
reactions
to her
um scarring
do not mask
the restricted Demi life she led
throughout that time
what a remarkable and impressive woman
she must have been
you have very little personal mitigation
you are not a young man when you did
this and cannot say that you're in an
immature youth
nor have you turned your life around
since 1999 the parole board considered
that you remained a danger for a number
of years after you're eligible to be
considered for release
when you were released on license in
2015 your behavior led to you being
recalled to custody within three years
as you had returned to drinking knowing
actually that drinking was linked to
your violence against women
in some cases where there is a lengthy
delay between an unlawful act and death
a defendant is entitled to considerable
credit for having made the most of
themselves
particularly when the assault that
caused the later death occurred when
they were young
but that does not apply in your case
that the best that can be said is that
you now have some insight into your
difficult relationship with alcohol and
some awareness of your misogyny
also little weight can be given to you
for the passage of time because of the
horrendous injuries and reduced quality
of life that Jackie and her family
enjoyed over that same passage of time
their plight is relevant too
I I accept of course I do that you had
no intention to kill Jackie which is
ordinarily an important mitigating
Factor
but again in your case this has reduced
significance almost to vanishing point
because the risk of her dying from what
you did to her was so obvious even if it
was not your intention
I acknowledge that when you saw her in
flames you were shocked and said to her
that you did not intend it to happen
but if you had done something more to
help her other than ordering her to roll
over and keep us clear from her as
possible it would have been more to your
credit
you have already been sentenced for
causing Jackie Grievous bodily harm with
intent and as a matter of Justice you
must not serve longer in custody because
you have been sentenced for two offenses
based on identical facts
the proper way of dealing with this is
to reduce the minimum term that I impose
by the total amount of time that you
have spent in custody for your attack on
Jackie
and by that I mean
from you being remanded in custody
before the first trial to serving part
of the notional determinate sentence it
also includes the time after the
specified period of nine years when the
parole board did not consider you safe
to be released and it also includes the
two periods when you were recalled to
custody after you had been released on
license
the total period of your incarceration
uh related to the of a fence on Jackie
as at today's date is agreed at 11 year
eight sorry 18 years 11 months and 25
days
so from a starting point of 30
the aggravating factors of such cruel
Behavior towards Jackie so lacking
inhumanity for the reasons I've set out
would take the Tariff to 35 and a half
years
but you are entitled to some allowance
for your limited mitigation your lack of
intention to kill the progress such as
it is that you have made in prison and
more minimally still the passage of time
I've also taken account of your sense of
disappointment that after having been
released in 2019 because of Jack's death
you are now facing a second long period
of imprisonment based on exactly the
same facts
those mitigating factors would entitle
you to a total deduction of 18 months
from the minimum period appropriate for
your offense
which would therefore take it to 34
years
taking into account the period of 18
years 11 months and 25 days I therefore
set the minimum term at 15 years and
five days
in other words if I can put it more
simply
your murder of Jackie justifies a total
minimum term of imprisonment of 34 years
in your life sentence but because you
have already served nearly 19 years for
causing the Grievous bodily harm that
she so bravely endured for 21 years the
term I now impose of 15 years and five
days is the balance that would bring the
local minimum term to 34 years
it's important that you and everyone
concerned with this case should
understand what this means
the minimum term is not a fixed term
after which you will automatically be
released
it is the term that must be served
before the parole board can undertake
their first review of the case
they will then review the risk that you
present at that stage and will consider
whether you can properly be released
from custody subject to license and if
so what the terms of that license should
be
if you are released you will be subject
to license for the rest of your life
if for any reason your license is
revoked you'll be recalled to prison to
continue to serve your life sentence in
custody
it follows that unless and until the
parole board consider that your release
is appropriate
you will remain in custody
finally
I'm required to State an open court that
a surcharge of 190 pounds imposed by
section 42 of the sentencing act 2020
applies in your case and perhaps finally
finally the last word should go to the
family of Jackie for all that they have
endured and the way they have stood by
her and cared for her over this long and
difficult period
and finally finally finally can I thank
all the lawyers in this case who've
helped with this difficult and
distressing
case
thank you very much indeed